the Joe Rogan experience that was the
other thing I was thinking about this
cowboy versus Connor fight that's the
most Irish guy versus the most American
guy
it's Bud Light verse proper would actual
bud he's not a trash the real [ __ ] [ __ ]
your life blood light if you're like
eating clams or something you want
something cold dude its Budweiser first
proper whiskey that's what I'm saying
and I like my Budweiser in a can I like
to know I'm a fleshy [ __ ] me too is
Connor reaching for his whiskey while
Cowboys reaching for his Budweiser I
mean I guess I wish they would have done
it in like Dublin or something like a
giant stadium in Dublin where are they
doing it Vegas I guess well they
probably had an agreement with Vegas
anyway see I think the thing about Vegas
is like there's the most people that can
come it's easy to get to there's the
most amount of hotels you make the most
money yeah make the most money you make
the most it's it's look it's gonna be
[ __ ] great just on TV or watch it
live it's gonna be [ __ ] great I can't
wait and if Connor can you know can
catch him early they could be very
interested it's literally uh you know a
sprint versa marathon because because
cowboy has stick around and yeah you
know five rounds for counter at
welterweight it scares me man if cowboy
can use his distance and he's very good
at doing it you know and he can avoid
that straight left you know cuz Connors
got a piston over left hand
I think Connor is better with his hands
but Cowboys better with his feet and
also the one thing everyone's forgetting
is cowboy can [ __ ] wrestle man in any
anomalous addition so yeah if he wants
to pull that out it's a point of the
fight he can definitely do it
I don't think he's going I don't think
he's going on the Mike Perry fight
opened a lot of eyes cuz Mike Perry is a
gorilla gorilla that guy is [ __ ]
strong as [ __ ] and when when cowboy arm
Bardem you know Mike Perry sent him a
picture of x-rays of a broken arm that
wasn't really his arm oh really this
what you did to my arm so he's like oh
hell no and cowboys are but they really
didn't really break his arm Wow and I
said what's that about he was a strange
guy
fake broken arm in the x-ray this arm
wasn't broken they didn't like Perry you
do like 21 I mean there's like 0.01% of
black and you just start dropping then
like it's just out of nowhere was like
what the [ __ ] is happening like Perry's
wild dude he's hilarious is what is this
a platinum tattooed on his eyebrow is it
yeah I don't know he's wild real here's
a fight coming up yeah who is he
fighting he's fighting someone good
right Jeff Neil is he fighting Jeff Neil
yeah whoo that's a good fight
Jeff Neil do you know who we jelly how
sweet you know who we'd leave out when
we're talking about welterweight and
it's so [ __ ] up Leon Edwards he's
eight in a row
well how about Maz Vidale [ __ ] sucker
punch is open and it cuts his face and
they're in the you know the the middle
of this whole thing after he'd knocks
out til I know and he's in the heat of
this but it gets no traction there
wasn't yeah whatever he they actually
got in the fight straight fight yeah and
everyone's like yeah but Leon nobody
knows to you I'm sorry I know what but
he's one he's a monster
well he beat cowboy by decision but
cowboy was sick going into that fight
yeah not to say Leon couldn't have won
anyway but uh that's there's a guy who
never pulls out of a fight where the
last time you heard cowboy pull out of a
fire never he would have to be on
death's door again he he's been a
yes-man for the UFC's gone through so
much [ __ ] kind of weight on three days
notice and fighting this time losing
Sarah Lee even then he's a yes-man it's
like he's just down to fight all right
but for but at some times it's not for
the best of his career like when he
fought Maas at all in Denver's home time
the hometown after the Mike Brown fight
we like did he suffered a lot of damage
like dude fight in hometown
whatever four weeks later he's like yeah
alright you know I'm saying like that
usually your work because you're like
gonna be honest with you to get to the
title that doesn't make a lot of sense
I'm positive the Dane has actually told
them that to it so at certain points I
was not blaming Dana I think that he
wanted fights were Dana was like look
just slow down I'm sure I'm in but Isis
wild nights a while dude but it's paid
usually it doesn't pay off it's paid off
he got his golden news goose well he's
in an interesting stage where he's doing
a lot of fights so he's really
comfortable fighting right he's fighting
very regular
and he also you know at that age where
his brain and his his knowledge of
fighting his fight IQ is at its highest
while his body's still hanging in there
hanging in there though but there's a
fine line where it's let's say you got
knocked out by Gaetti right so let's say
Conor knocks out then it's like I what
are we doing exactly because you're in
he's like 36 now oh yeah 37 so this is
you know this is the area right from 36
to 40 is where you see you know some
guys bernard hopkins it and they just
[ __ ] eat nothing but grilled chicken
with perfectly cooked vegetables that's
the most except he's the the the most
odd exception cuz bernard hopkins was
elite as a boxer with no drugs no
nothing
yeah
MMA really can't get away also could
control the pace where he could dictate
like how fast you guys fought so nobody
could just put a pace on him and then
they're not like no it's a different
animal it's a completely different
animal and the only guys have really
made it successfully deep into their 40s
were not on the match no you know and
you know the early days of fighting man
you got to realize like the early days
everything has to have an asterik
everything every kind of is the Wild
West was like everyone did it you know
because it was kind of a level playing
field
[Applause]